one of the strangest celebrations or
holidays in Sweden is probably the one
referred to locally as luciaa or
basically St Lucy's day it's celebrated
every year on December 13 and is
actually very popular schools will
organize musical performances people
sing specific songs and eat pastries
together at the same time most people
either don't know or don't care what
this holiday is actually about it's deep
Catholic Roots is lost on most people
even though the symbolism is very clear
so what is the story of Lucia or St LC's
day where does it come from uh what are
its Origins and characteristics and why
is it with the exception of Italy
basically only celebrated in
[Applause]
Scandinavia this video is a
collaboration with my friend and
colleague Dr Angela po
from the YouTube channel Angela's
Symposium it's a great pleasure and
honor to work together with such amazing
people uh we've worked together in the
past as many of you probably know and
this year we're doing a kind of um
Christmas or holiday special here Dr
Angela puka is a religious studies PhD
and University lecturer who disseminated
academic peer-reviewed scholarship on
topics like magic esotericism paganism
Shamanism and the Occult in the
companion episode to this one she'll
discuss the his iCal links between
Christmas and midwinter Pagan festivals
like you so don't forget to check that
out you can find uh the links to her
video in the description and of course
in a Pinn comment if you haven't checked
out her channel in General yet then you
should definitely go do that Angela's
work over on Angela Symposium is simply
fantastic she's doing some of the best
uh religious studies content out there
uh so definitely go support our Channel
check out the companion video to this
one to find out more about Christmas and
Ule and the celebrations or connections
there but also just go subscribe to her
channel for some truly amazing religious
studies content every year on December
13 sweets will gather to watch a
performance either perhaps at your kid'
school in a proper opera house or just
on the TV there will be a visual and
musical performance of what is known as
luciaa or with the proper pronunciation
Luchia usually a woman with candles of
light in her hair will be leading A
procession of other women boys dressed
as gingerbread men or Santa Claus all
holding candles while they sing songs
associated with this particular holiday
this celebration of Lucia or St Lucy's
day is a staple of the larger Christmas
season here in Sweden it's technically
not Christmas or connected to Christmas
but it's it's sort of seen as a as part
of the wider Christmas season Christmas
songs are sung during these performances
and it's just part of the holiday season
it's it's a staple actually the holiday
season here in Sweden but where does
this holiday actually come from Luchia
of Syracuse or St Lucy the main figure
at the center of the celebrations was a
Christian Saint during the 3rd to Fourth
centuries in Syracuse in Sicily stories
say that she came from a wealthy family
but at a young age devoted herself to
God when her mother wanted to arrange a
marriage for her Lucy refused and after
signs from God the mother decided to
follow her daughter's wish and instead
on her request gave the da to the needy
and poor in
Sicily another famous story also says
that Luchia herself would go down into
the catacombs with food for the poor
Christians that were hiding there from
persecution this was after all during
the famous persecution of Christians
under the Roman Emperor Diocesan
whatever the case she was eventually
reported to the authorities who arrested
her later sources say that she had to
withstand torture among other things
having her eyes gouged out before being
killed by a sword to the throat St Lucy
or Luchia became a martyr and a saint of
the church and a day of commemoration
for her developed over the centuries
that took place on December
13th eventually as we know Christianity
would spread northward and all the way
to Scandinavia where stories about the
Saints and their deeds were told and
their days of commemoration became
popular here as well the strange thing
about this holiday though is that even
though um Scandinavia became Protestant
after the Reformation and thus basically
did away with everything to do with
Saints and commemorating the Saints of
the Catholic Church St Lucy's day or
Luchia is still widely celebrated and
very popular in Scandinavia so why is
this what's going on here well there
could be several reasons for this which
touch on topics were discussed in
various other videos about Christian
appropriation and syncretism as well as
the general attitude towards religion in
Scandinavia and the sociology of ritual
one of the most interesting and probably
important aspects of this story is that
even though the holiday clearly has
Catholic themes and symbolism aspects of
the Luchia celebration might predate
Christianity in the
region you see when the holiday was
established the Julian calendar was used
and in this calendar December 13th was
the darkest day of the year in other
words the winter solstice this was
before we changed to the Gregorian
calendar and the winter solstice mooved
to to December 21st or
22nd and in many cultures including
Scandinavia the winter soltice was
celebrated in different
ways it was long thought that dark
Forces of the world roamed on this
darkest day of the year and people would
stay up to guard their houses from those
evil forces there is often talk about
something called Lucy or lingan an evil
female being that would fly around
almost like a witch on this particular
day with her evil followers the word Luc
survives into modern celebrations but
its Origins is somewhat uncertain its
similarity to the name Luchia or Lucia
is interesting at least the latter is
clearly associated with the word for
light looks in Latin indeed the day was
also strongly associated with light
especially in the Nordic countries
winter can get pretty dark and we only
get a few hours of light every day on
this very darkest day of the year it was
important thus to to so to say keep the
light on uh by things like U you know
lighting candles and so on there is even
some evidence to suggest that
pre-christian Scandinavians might have
had a conception of a kind of female
goddess or a spiritual being of light
that would be evoked or worshiped on
this particular day she was thought to
bring light to this dark period of the
year the inquisitive viewer might have
already started to see connections here
St Lucy or Luchia in in celebrations
here in Scandinavia is always portrayed
with candles with light in other words
in her hair and also functions as a
symbol for bringing light into the
darkness in modern Lucia
celebrations so here we might have
another clear example of Christian
syncretism as Christianity spread to new
regions it often adapted to local
customs and vice versa in the case of
Luchia the celebrations of the Catholic
saint and the pre-existing local
celebrations of the winter solstice
which involved symbolism of lights
associated with a female figure if this
is true this might have been syncretized
in such a way just like with sawin and
All Saints Day the church probably saw
an opportunity to take an already
existing popular tradition and give it a
new Christian language and clothing over
time symbols and aspects of both were
probably merged in different ways to
create the celebrations as we know it
today this was a common practice and has
been a common practice across history
for Christians in their encounters with
new new cultures and and local customs
in different regions where Christianity
would uh enter and and and and you know
try to to convert the population um
similar things happen as we said with
with sawin and All Saints Day similar
things also probably happened with
Christmas which again is what Angela is
going to be tackling in her video so
don't forget to check that video out um
there's a lot of misconceptions about
Christmas and the origins of Christmas
and how it's connected to Christianity
and so on so I highly recommend you go
check out her video cuz it she's going
to explain it in a in a scholarly and
proper way um so that you'll get a
better overview of of that situation the
first documented case of a St Lucy in
Sweden particularly with the imagery of
carrying candles in her hair is from the
early 19th century so some of these
syncretic elements probably took some
time to develop and it is indeed in the
last two centuries that the modern Lucia
celebr celebrations as we know it in
Scandinavia has started to develop and
today as we've said is a very popular
and widespread tradition it might have
started in the western parts of Sweden
but has since spread to the entire
country on December 13th everyone knows
it is Luchia or Lucia and like we said
it's really fascinating that this
particular holiday is so common and so
popular in Scandinavia of all of all
places where you know Catholicism has
not been the majority for of
Christianity for a long time and you
know celebrating the saint
Luchia is a thing in Italy still which
isn't that weird since she came from
Italy she was from Sicily after all
although you know some Sicilians might
say that that's not part of Italy but
whatever we're not can get political
here um and and angelot actually tells
me that the Luchia celebrations in in
Italy are pretty similar to the can of
celebrations that we do here with the
kind of procession and all the these
kind of things but at the same time time
aside from Italy as far as I know at
least it's basically only in the Nordic
countries in like Scandinavia where this
is a thing which is strange since again
Scandinavia is a Protestant
country and of all the kind of saints
and all these commemorations why Luchia
so I I I think the answer partly lies in
well it's it's probably very complex and
there are different aspects to it I
think one one important factor here is
this idea that there might have been a
pre-christian tradition uh of the winter
solstice that included a lot of this
imagery and similar ideas that was then
sort of appropriated and syncretized
with the Christian tradition which has
sort of allowed it to continue also the
idea that uh Lucia brings light in in
this darkest time of the year that whole
sort of symbolism uh which is one of the
aspects that do go back probably to
pre-christian times that that seems to
be something that a lot of people really
really resonate with and also probably
because it's it's just become a thing
right sometimes people do things just
because it's a thing they do there
doesn't have to be all these complex
reasons behind it people just like to
celebrate Lucia and so that's you know
it's it's that's why it's become such a
big deal in Scandinavia I think there
are different reasons U and complex
reasons like that behind it while at the
same time maybe being pretty simple on
December 13 Local Schools will organize
Lucia processions where one person
usually a girl although this has started
to diversify in the last few years is
chosen to play the role of Lucia or
Luchia and others participate in the
procession behind her wearing different
kinds of costumes but all carrying
candles in their hand thus continuing
the symbolism of bringing light into the
darkness in this way they will then sing
songs associated with the holiday
talking about St Lucy St Steven or just
general Christmas songs they're also
more official national processions aired
on national TV or performed in
established musical venues seeing a
professional group do such a performance
can be a truly breathtaking and
beautiful experience um I've been to a
few of those kinds of performances or
processions in a more sort of
professional
environment and it's a really profound
thing just to see a completely dark room
just filled up with with these little
lights and then you know in cases where
it's a professional choir singing These
beautiful songs it it's a it can be
truly it can be a really powerful thing
sometimes the symbolism here can be a
little unclear right uh Luchia and the
candles and all that that that kind of
makes sense right but what about people
in the this procession being dressed as
gingerbread men and Santa Claus like
there can't be a connect like what's
what's the connection here there can't
be any connection between that and and
this Catholic saint or any kind of
pre-christian tradition and frankly no
of course there isn't any connection but
this shows you once again how Traditions
like this develop and change there will
always be adjustments made based on time
and place like I mentioned earlier few
swedes or Scandinavians really have any
idea about the complex history and
symbolism behind this actual holiday
they've probably heard about St Lucy I
know that the celebration is about her
but that is about the extent of their
knowledge and interest also really for
many it's a day that celebrates light
which feels especially relevant in the
darkness of the Scandinavian Winters but
perhaps above all and just like most
rituals and traditions it has a social
purpose rituals of different sorts
create a sense of order regardless of
what the symbolism or reason behind the
rituals are scholarship shows again and
again that rituals are performed first
and explained secondly we all have
rituals that we perform daily a certain
morning routine a certain way of
brushing our teeth Etc and we need those
kinds of familiar things and structures
in our lives especially on a social
level rituals and traditions have a very
strong way of bringing people together
of making them feel like they are part
of a group or part of a larger context
celebrating St LC's day for most people
isn't about commemorating a Catholic
saint from the 4th Century it's about us
the traditions we create and take part
in together and how that gives our lives
meaning and strengthens our identities
both individually and collectively again
don't forget to check check out the
companion video to this one by Dr Angela
puka over on Angela Symposium um I'm
going to say this again you should
definitely go subscribe to her Channel
um it's some of the best religious
studies content out there especially if
you're interested in these kinds of
topics like Shamanism and paganism um
Alchemy uh Magic uh the occult and the
esoteric these are she's a she's truly
an expert in these cancer topics and she
covers them so well so go check out her
channel uh check out the companion video
to this one about Christmas letter know
that I sent you uh thank you all so much
for watching this video and I will see
you next
[Music]
time